[Music]
[Applause]
one of the government's biggest secrets
is hiding in plain sight
in las vegas janet is the top secret
government airline
that doesn't exist let's find out why
all right here's what you do next time
you're in vegas visit one of the big
casinos next to mccarran airport
i'm talking about luxor excalibur
mandalay bay
you're going there anyway so when you
get there look east at the airport
okay all day long but especially early
in the morning and late in the evening
you'll see mysterious planes taking off
and landing and you can't miss them
they're big they're boeing 737s and
and they have no markings no logos
they're plain white with a single red
stripe
this is janet airlines where are we
going with this
well janet is a top secret air force
owned commuter airline
for civilians and janet's mission is to
fly
employees contractors and government
vips into and out of
america's top secret installations okay
i'm interested
but the destination janet goes to the
most i'm talking
a few times a day is please say it
please say it
area 51 yes grab your tinfoil hat
[Music]
an airline call sign is how planes are
identified on the radio
and call signs are often simple like
american 441
or delta four and sometimes call signs
have a little more pizzazz
like british airways uses speed bird and
china airlines uses the call sign
dynasty then there's the call sign janet
just in it for years janet has been a
mystery
it's an airline that really isn't an
airline the fleet uses no logos or
special markings of any kind
but for years janet has been operating
in plain sight
taking hundreds of people into and out
of mccarran airport in las vegas every
day
now the only way to fly janet is if
you're a government contractor or
employee
with very very high security clearance
don't
don't just show up at the terminal
who could you point me to at the base
who could give me some information okay
what i want to tell you right now you're
trespassing on private property
is it is it government property or is it
just no comment your trespassing
are you trying to kid bud i just you
wanna
me and quit it janet isn't even the
airline's real name
it officially doesn't have one though
people have said it stands for
joint air network for employee
transportation or
just another non-existent terminal ooh
creepy
now if you didn't know any better
day-to-day activity at the janet
terminal looks completely normal
overnight there are only 20 or 30 cars
in the parking lot but during the day
there are hundreds of cars parked there
people show up in civilian clothing
they get on the planes they go to work
most of the passengers fit on 4737s
they're gone all day they come back in
the evening get in their cars and they
go home
just no big whoop but where do these
people actually go every day
well the government won't tell us in
fact the government hasn't acknowledged
that janet
even exists naturally so let's do some
digging
janet planes have airline codes and
flight numbers just like regular
commercial planes
and just like typical planes janet's
planes are equipped with transponders
that allow them to be tracked
using a few websites linked below you
can track almost every flight in the
world
but something strange happens when you
track a janet flight
as soon as it gets about 20 minutes
north of las vegas
the plane vanishes whoa you know what's
up there area 51.
the government officially calls it homey
airport or groom lake but yeah that's
area 51.
well how do we know well first of all
unless it's an emergency planes are
required to keep their transponders on
but when a janet airline enters area 51
airspace
it turns off its transponder every time
and second of all
the airspace around area 51 is highly
restricted
but if you try to fly in without
permission best case scenario is you'll
be escorted out by fighter jets
worst case scenario you'll be turned
into scrap metal by fighter jets
either way there's fighter jets janet
also flies to air force plant 42
the tonal pop military test range and
the china lake weapons testing facility
now these are the most restricted air
spaces in the world
but somehow every day janna airlines fly
in and out of them without a problem
okay so here's the current janet fleet
hey uh should we be showing this what
this is public information yeah that
wasn't my question
what was that do you hear that
so using the fleet information you can
go to the faa website and see who owns
the plane so
let's do that bingo right
okay so this definitely is a us
government plane that is owned by the us
air force
considering the patterns of the flights
it's safe to conclude that the planes
are definitely taking government
employees to the facilities where they
work but the destinations are also
classified frequently a janet flight
will tell the tower it's going to one
place but
actually goes somewhere completely
different the government lies well you
can knock me over with a feather
but janet is not technically operated by
the government
it operates like a civilian airline okay
so if the air force owns the airline but
doesn't operate it
who does
so who actually operates janet airlines
a little cyber sleuthing gives us more
clues
area 51 was originally established by
the cia as a secure
airport for testing advanced aircraft
and testing other things
in the early 70s authority of the base
transferred from the cia to the air
force
at that time employees were either bused
in or they took shuttle flights from
lockheed martin in burbank california
lockheed martin again yep and for you
guys that are new to this channel
it seems like we can't get through a
single conspiracy video without
lockheed martin coming up this is not an
accident it doesn't seem to be
a few years later janet operation was
transferred to defense contractor eg
g and eeg was one of the companies who
helped develop the atomic bomb so
so they were involved in shady stuff
they were
eg g bought a few used planes from china
transitioned the fleet to boeing 737s
and moved the op to gold coast terminal
in las vegas now if you google the
location of the janet airlines terminal
you get something called the aecom
hangar which google describes as a
non-governmental organization
suspicious i thought so too so let's
backtrack
a ecom hangar used to be called the gold
coast terminal
the original operator of the gold coast
was defense contractor eg
g how do we know it was zg g well they
posted a job listing saying so and i'll
link it below
now eg g was acquired by the carlyle
group in 1999
which was acquired by the urs
corporation in 2002 which was acquired
by aecom in 2014
so a ecom hangar that's a huckleberry
yep so what does aecom do well the
company describes itself very vaguely
as a global network of design
engineering construction and management
professionals
partnering with clients to imagine and
deliver a better world
weird salad with revenues of 18 billion
word salad with government contracts
yep and there's more aecom recently
posted a job opening for a first officer
slash co-pilot in las vegas nevada the
preferred qualifications include boeing
737 experience
okay and high performance and or jet
aircraft experience
okay the job listing doesn't make any
reference to janet
but candidates must qualify for and
maintain a top-secret government
security clearance yep yes janet
definitely janet this week we've heard
the contention of ufo researchers that
there is a secret government within our
government
while that may be hard to believe coming
from the ufo perspective
we've certainly learned in watergate and
the iran contra scandal
that factions within our government can
and do pursue pursue their own hidden
agendas
outside of the law outside the control
of congress or the knowledge
of the american people
area 51 is inside the nevada test and
training range which is made up of
smaller distinct areas
with different purposes and many
sections are designated
area x so yes there is an area 49
and area 50 and area 52 and so on now
surrounding area 51
is nellis air force range which covers a
huge amount of southern nevada now
at various points in time area 51 has
been called the watertown strip
dreamland paradise ranch homey airport
the area
the remote location or out of town isn't
that cute
or sometimes it's simply referred to as
nowhere nowhere
it's a place we've been there it sucks
area 51
has been home to some of america's most
highly secret aviation programs
among other things this is where the u2
spy plane and lockheed a12 were secretly
tested where the f-117 nighthawk stealth
attack aircraft was developed before
being deployed to the gulf and now who
really knows what's hiding in the
hangars
gateway identified but we do know
that on average about a thousand people
a day take janet planes from vegas to
area 51 and back could they be working
on the lockheed sr-72
a spy plane capable of mach 6 or 4 600
miles an hour
are they working on the b-21 raider a
new generation of stealth bomber
that can deliver a nuclear weapon
anywhere in the world or
he says he was hired to work at an area
called s4 which is a few miles south of
groom lake
at s4 he says are flying saucers
anti-matter reactors and other working
examples of technology that is seemingly
beyond human capabilities
right this this came from somewhere else
i mean as bizarre as that is to believe
but i mean it's there
i saw it i know what the current state
of the art is
in in physics and it's it can't be done
could these people be commuting from las
vegas on a secret airline to work on
extraterrestrial spacecraft i think so
it's possible nobody really knows but
every year we seem to get closer to some
kind of reveal
for years the government denied area 51
even existed but finally admitted it in
and after years of denial the cia just
released a bunch of ufo documents
acknowledging they
exist and a full document dump is
happening later this year
air force and navy pilots are coming
forward with stories and footage
major news organizations are covering
ufos as legitimate stories
every day for at least a couple years
wait a minute
every day for a couple of years ufos
aren't fringe anymore
people regular normal people want to
know what's going on
the us government won't acknowledge that
janet airlines exists but
that's okay we know that it does
considering the ubiquity of information
today
and the speed at which it travels it's
becoming more and more difficult for
governments to keep secrets from its
citizens
and overall that's a good thing
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything today
do me a favor like subscribe
comment and share the algorithm is like
a top secret area 51 project but with
your help
we can learn the truth until next time
be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you